okay
la no no security
presence
foreign
goof
Jordan a prison
or representative
[Music]
services
foreign
foreign
until
a good place
[Music]
the situation however
today
questions
declaration
conformation
Carlo
thank you
Mr President the exceptional level of
attention to the war in Ukraine reflects
the widespread Global concern about its
dangerous and far-reaching concept
dangerous and far-reaching consequences
this concern can only deepen as the most
recent developments in the war are
ominous pointing to More Death
destruction and suffering
indeed since the last council meeting on
Ukraine on 22 September we have seen
actions that threaten to further
escalate the conflict
as we meet so-called referenda were just
conducted by de facto authorities in the
danetsk luhansk her son and zaparesia
regions
ukrainians were asked whether they
approved their regions joining the
Russian Federation
voting took place in polling centers
de facto authorities accompanied by
soldiers also went door to door with
ballot boxes
these exercises which began on 23
September have been held during active
armed conflict in areas under Russian
control and outside Ukraine's legal and
constitutional framework
they cannot be called a genuine
expression of the popular will
unilateral actions aim to provide a
veneer of legitimacy to the attempted
acquisition by force by one state of
another State's territory
while claiming to represent the will of
the people cannot be regarded as legal
under international law
let me reiterate here that the United
Nations remains fully committed to the
sovereignty Unity Independence and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
in accordance with relevant U.N
resolutions
I'd like to recall that as the occupying
power the Russian Federation is obliged
under International humanitarian law to
respect the laws of Ukraine in the
administration of occupied territories
the president the past few weeks have
also seen heavy fighting in southern
Ukraine in the direction of her son and
zaparesia
as well as escalating military
operations in Donetsk and luhansk
regions
in mid-september the Ukrainian military
undertook a successful counter-offensive
to restore Ukrainian control over most
of the russian-held areas in harkif
region
we have continued to see not only daily
attacks on many Ukrainian cities cities
including in Donetsk and luhansk but
also the targeting of Civilian energy in
water infrastructure reportedly by
Russian forces
recent reports of drone attacks in and
around Odessa are also deeply disturbing
to date
ohchr has recorded 14 844 civilian
casualties
with
5996 persons killed and
8848 injured
this is 278 more civilians killed and
six 649 were injured since I last
briefed this Council on 7 September
these are verified individual incidents
actual figures are likely considerably
higher
we've also heard alarming rhetoric
regarding the use of nuclear weapons
this is unacceptable
such rhetoric is inconsistent with the
joint statement of the leaders of the
five nuclear weapon States on preventing
nuclear war and avoiding arms races made
on three January 2022
let me reiterate the secretary General's
appeal for all nuclear armed States
including the Russian Federation to
recommit to the non-use and Progressive
elimination of nuclear weapons
Mr President admitted these Grim
developments the United Nations
continues to work to alleviate the
suffering caused by the war to support
accountability for violations and abuses
of Human Rights and violations of
international humanitarian law
and to prevent the deterioration of the
already volatile situation around
Ukraine's nuclear sites
un and partner organizations need safe
and unimpeded access to deliver
life-saving assistance to All In Need
in the areas of harkif region back under
Ukrainian control they were able to
organize silverlade convoys
however in areas outside government
control in Donetsk luhans her son
nikolaev and zaparesia regions access is
the biggest challenge
Mr President the human rights monitoring
mission in Ukraine continues to report
on violations of human rights and
international humanitarian law
we are gravely concerned by allegations
of violations committed in parts of
Northeastern Ukraine including after the
recovery of over 400 bodies from
improvised graves in museum
ohchr is working with local authorities
to investigate this in other allegations
of human rights violations and abuses in
areas in harkif region that were until
recently under Russian control
there are other extremely disturbing
reports
following investigations in the areas of
Kiev Journey Heath and Sumi the
independent International Commission of
inquiry on Ukraine mandated by the U.N
Human Rights Council has concluded that
war crimes were committed in Ukraine
among other findings the commission was
struck by the large number of executions
and other violations carried out by
Russian forces
in the four areas it covered the
commission has processed two incidents
of ill treatment against Russian
Federation Soldiers by Ukrainian forces
rarely if ever as the International
Community collected so much evidence of
human rights violations potential war
crimes and other atrocities as they were
happening
it is tragic that we have not been able
to stop them
but it would be shameful if we were not
able to ensure Justice for the victims
and their loved ones
those responsible for the outrages being
committed in Ukraine
wherever they sit must be brought to
account
Mr President we remain deeply troubled
by reports of continuing attacks as
recently as last week in the vicinity of
the zaparisia nuclear power plants the
U.N continues to support the efforts of
the international atomic energy agency
we urge all concerned to provide maximum
cooperation with iaea
it is imperative that all attacks on
nuclear facilities end and that the
purely civilian nature of such plants be
re-established
Mr President by now the global
implications of this war on food and
energy security felt by millions of
people are well known
during the general debate many member
states decried this predicament
the Black Sea grain initiative continues
to gather Pace with more than 4.5
million metric tons of foodstuff shift
from Ukrainian ports including to the
Horn of Africa Yemen and Afghanistan
efforts to remove remaining obstacles to
the export of Russian food products and
fertilizers also continue
these products are not under sanctions
and it is crucial to get them back to
World Markets
averting a global food crisis makes it
vital to renew the black seed grain deal
when it expires at the end of November
Mr President in remarks to the general
assembly the Secretary General warned
that the U.N Charter and its ideals are
in jeopardy
and that we have a duty to act
I repeat his appeal to all member states
to help prevent further escalation and
to do all we can to end the war and
ensure lasting peace in accordance with
the principles of the charter and
international law thank you Mr President
expose
thank you
ladies and gentlemen
dear members of the UN Security Council
who respect and fulfill the UN Charter
dear representatives of states and
leaders who are listening to me now the
UN Security Council is the institution
that works according to well-known and
well-defined rules this regulation which
is still being followed even by the
representatives of Russia so far
they haven't been using weapons instead
of words in this room they're not
knocking out a chair from their
neighbors in the security Council but
surely no one will be surprised if this
room of the U.N security Council will be
turned into a zone of Violence by
representatives of Russia Russia already
despises the Yuan Charter Russia is
already breaking any rules of this work
of this world
so it's only a matter of time before it
destroys these last International
institution which can still function
that is why it is now that I'm calling
upon you for actions anyone in the world
can now give hundreds of examples as how
Russia violates the international legal
order and destroys the main body of
international law it constantly provokes
escalation and constantly responds to
any proposals for talks with a new
brutality on the battlefield with even
greater crisis and threats to Ukraine
and the world these are all these things
I will name only five
only what is already happening right now
first Russia has ignored the iaea call
for the immediate deoccupation of the
zapparesia nuclear plant and the
determination of any hostile actions
against technical nuclear facilities of
Ukraine this fact it's a additional
proof that Russia is deliberately
keeping the world on the brink of
radiation disaster the second is a
nuclear blackmail the threats of using
nuclear weapons have become a constant
Narrative of Russian officials and
propagandists this proves that Russia
has no right to possess nuclear weapons
as it is unable to guarantee the safety
of the world even against the threats of
using nuclear weapons third last week
I've presented the UN General Assembly
the Ukrainian peace formula Russia's
response to this real pass to peace was
the announcement of mobilization
besides Russia deliberately focuses its
mobilization on the indigenous people
from the territories at control these
are not only the the caucuses or Siberia
where everything is being done to
mobilize as many male as possible from
indigenous population but it's also
about Crimea the Ukrainian Crimea which
Russia has seized back in 2014 among all
the ethnic groups of Crimea the male
indigenous people of Crimean Terrors
received the most of Russian draft
notices that's in proportion to the
total number
this is a
genocidal policy Frankly Speaking the
fourth point in front of the eyes of the
whole world Russia is conducting this
so-called sham referendum on the
occupied territory of Ukraine
people
are forced to fill out some papers while
being threatened by submachine guns all
for a nice TV cover this alleged results
of the Sham referenda have been prepared
well in advance just as this compulsory
issue of passports for the population of
the occupied territories now what's the
reason for that and the answer is in the
next point the fifth one the annexation
of the capture territories this is the
most brutal violation of the U.N Charter
this is an attempt to steal the
territory of another state this is an
attempt to erase the Norms of
international law there's a very cynical
attempt to force the male population and
occupied territory of Ukraine to
mobilize into the Russian army in order
to send them to fight against their own
Homeland
there is only one way to stop this all
first it's a complete isolation of
Russia in response to everything it does
a state cannot remain a permanent member
to the U.N security Council with the
right of veto if such a state is waging
a genocidal policy right now skipping
the world one step away from a radiation
disaster and at the same time it keep on
threatening with nuclear strikes Russia
should be excluded from all
International organizations if such an
exclusion is procedurally complicated
then its participation should be
suspended second there is a need for new
and tough Global sanctions against
Russia any annexation in the modern
world is a crime a crime against all
states that consider the inviolability
of borders to be vital for themselves
third any Russian criminal actions do
not change anything for us we do not to
come to the black male of terrorists it
is in Ukraine and in this war that not
only our independence has been defended
not only the right to life for our
people but also the international law as
such Ukraine must receive all the
necessary defense and financial support
so the aggressor would lose fourth
Ukraine should receive clear and legally
bonding guarantees of collective
security
since the independence of our country is
of such a fundamental importance for
many elements of Global Security the
world also needs a respective security
architecture and fifths
that's very important I want everyone to
understand this
Russia's recognition of these sham
referenders as normal the implementation
of the so-called crimein scenario and
another attempt to Annex Ukrainian
territory will mean that there is
nothing
to talk about with this President of
Russia annexation is the kind of move
that puts him alone against the whole of
humanity such a clear signal is now
needed from every country in the world I
believe in your ability to act I thank
to the French presidency for the
opportunity to participate in this
meeting thank you all for your attention
glory to Ukraine
foreign
and thank you to under Secretary General
Rosemary DeCarlo
for your briefing today thank you
president zielinski for your statement
colleagues a little more than seven
months ago
just seven months we met at night in
this chamber to discuss how we could
preserve peace in Ukraine
at that moment Putin chose War instead
the timing could not be clearer Putin
was showing exactly what he thought of
this Council
last week leaders from more than a
hundred countries from around the world
gathered in New York to reaffirm their
commitment to the U.N Charter and many
of the key principles it stands for
sovereignty territorial integrity and
peace and security
instead of attending high level week
Putin announced A Renewed conscription
effort in Russia and instructed areas
under Russia's military control to
prepare for illegitimate snap referenda
he did send an invincere emissary who
threatened the use of nuclear weapons on
a non-nuclear country to secure Russia's
illegitimate military gains
the purpose of all of this is clear
Russia intends to try to Annex these
territories and Russia does not respect
this body
the pattern is clear too
Putin intentionally chose this moment to
insult the charter that outlines
principles we all collectively stand for
sovereignty territorial Integrity peace
and security and he did this during the
most important week for the United
Nations high level week
Putin intends to commit an act which the
U.N Charter was expressly designed to
prevent an attempt by one U.N member
state to take the territory of another
by force
we know this will happen because it
follows a well-worn Kremlin Playbook
Russia runs sham referendum in areas
control by Russia's military and its
proxies coercing people to vote at
gunpoint
it then uses these referenda to try to
lend a semblance of legitimacy to its
attempted annexations of another
Sovereign States territory
the rush for Russia to Institute and
complete these attempted annexations
destroy even the facade of legitimacy
as Ukraine successfully regains control
over more of its territory that was
wrongfully seized by Russia and more of
Russia's atrocities are uncovered Russia
is rushing to draw a veil over its
military losses and the war crimes it
has committed
we know the outcomes of these sham
referenda were predetermined in Moscow
they in no way represent a legitimate
expression of the will of the Ukrainian
people the will of the Ukrainian people
is clear every day as they fight
valiantly for their country as they
protect their territorial Integrity as
they defend their sovereignty
the Ukrainian people have already
demonstrated they will never accept
being subjugated to Russian rule this
Council and the International Community
must do the same
so now let me be clear
the United States will never recognize
any territory Russia attempts to seize
or allegedly Annex as anything other
than part of Ukraine we reject Russia's
actions unequivocally and we will
continue to work with our allies
partners and like-minded to impose costs
on Russia and to provide historic
amounts of support for Ukraine
Justice demands nothing less
protecting the UN Charter demands
nothing less
in our many meetings here in the
security Council we've heard repeated
calls for the U.N Charter to be
respected but it is not enough to call
for respect of the U.N Charter we must
have the courage to defend it that means
standing up for Ukraine and the victims
of Russian atrocities it means Having
the courage to call out aggression and
attempts at naked territorial expansion
when we see it it means showing we care
about peace by demanding Russia honor
the U.N Charter
not doing so only enables Russia to
commit further abuses Russia started
this war and I hope that every member of
this Council will do the right thing by
standing up for international law and
the U.N Charter by calling on Russia to
end it now
Ukraine's fight is not only a fight for
survival
but a fight for democracy and very and
the Very principles that we all hold
dear that is why we will be tabling a
resolution condemning the Sham referenda
calling on member states not to
recognize any altered status of Ukraine
and obligating Russia to withdraw its
troops from Ukraine
Russia's sham referenda if accepted will
open a Pandora's Box that we cannot
close
we ask you to join us in reaffirming our
commitment to the U.N Charter and
meeting this challenge head on
if Russia chooses to Shield itself from
accountability here in the council we
will then look to the U.N General
Assembly to send an unmistakable message
to Moscow
the world must stand together and defend
the charter of the United Nations
have courage and support Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
this is about defending the U.N Charter
this is about defending our Collective
rights and this is about peace and
security for us all thank you Mr
President
is
colleagues
I would like to start by a quote which
reads
don't believe those who try to frighten
you with Russia and who scream that
other regions will follow after Crimea
we do not want a partition of Ukraine we
do not need this
this is what the president of Russia
said in 2014.
everyone can judge by themselves
I doubt though this comes as a surprise
to anyone
since for nine months now what we have
heard from the Russian delegation here
has little or nothing to do with what
happens there on the ground
two parallel realities
now let's have a closer look of what
will be known as the Sham referendums
being conducted these days by an
extensive use of kremlin's tricks
with the latest escalatory decisions and
the partial mobilization War has finally
entered into the Russian households and
we have seen the reactions Russians are
resisting they are protesting openly and
are massively leaving their country to
escape drafting because they do not know
why they should die in a war they do not
want and they do not understand
in the city of Kirsten election
officials went door to door with Riot
police it is a well-known fact when you
vote at gunpoint the process is more
expedite
the so-called voting has been recorded
on park benches in shops even in the
makeshift booths in the police stations
better known locally as the torture
chambers
which were put to such good use
elsewhere doors have been broken down to
facilitate the voting process
so much for the solemn moment of voting
so much for the oec rules and standards
yet the result is the No Doubt the vote
count engineered in Moscow with an
already scripted result will reveal that
residents would love to be ruled by the
invading power Russia
the haste with which these sham
referendums are being held makes it
unlikely that the spectacle will
convince anyone including Russian
themselves of their legitimacy
nobody in the world will take seriously
the result of people voting at gunpoint
of a referendum in the ruins
ladies and gentlemen
let's make it clear the Sham referendums
in luhansk the next the parisha and
Kirsten have nothing to do with
democracy nothing to do with free will
of ukrainians nothing to do with any
International election standard
they are just a replay of the same old
script applied in Georgia and Crimea now
they translate A desperate effort to
hide failure and a worthless attempt to
legitimize let images Conquest in the
eyes of an incredulous and deeply
troubled world
Russia is projecting Panic instead of
power instilling fear instead of force
and why such a heist because Ukraine
Army is astonishingly pushing Russia out
Russians were told that everything is
going to plan it never did
Russia knows that it's losing big
therefore what I have qualified before
here as the Russian referendum assembly
line was quickly put into action
we don't want more of Ukraine that
President Putin in 2014 and suddenly the
appetite of Kremlin has grown four fresh
territories are on the menu comprising
no less than 18 percent of the Ukraine
territory
Mr President international law prohibits
the occupier to change borders
Russia may claim that it has nothing to
do with these plans since they are held
and organized by the residents of the
regions but reality now and in the
recent past has shown clearly that this
is not true
by mid-march
Russian occupation authorities in
Kirsten and zapariza appointed
administrative leaders according to the
Ukrainian law heads of local state
administrations are proposed by the
cabinet of Ministers of Ukraine and
appointed by the president not by
Russian proxies
the Sham referendums are against the
constitution of Ukraine a referendum can
be called by the president of parliament
or by a public initiative involving the
valid signatures of at least 3 million
registered voters with at least one
hundred thousand such signatures coming
from every oblast
furthermore currently martial law
enforced in Ukraine prohibits holding of
any kind of Elections or referendums and
finally we have our own documents
according to unga resolution 3314
annexation by the use of force of the
territory of another state is in itself
an act of aggression
the sound referendums run against the
U.N Charter against U.N resolutions
against international law and are making
a mockery of the principles that Russia
has pledged to uphold the Supreme member
of the United Nations security Council
including when it threatens with the use
of weapons of mass destruction
Mr President as stated last week by
prime minister adirama at the unga we
strongly condemn Russia's ongoing war
and these premeditated mock elections in
Ukraine
they have zero legality zero legitimacy
zero credibility and Albania will not
recognize them the organization for
security and cooperation in Europe oece
the Excellence in monitoring elections
condemned what it qualified as illegal
referendum also attempts to compare
these referendums with other cases out
of every historic and political context
are simply worthless cynicism
we call on the old U.N members everyone
for whom the principles of territorial
Integrity sovereignty and inviability of
borders have a meaning to oppose
Russia's actions condemn the referendums
and their anticipated results and never
recognize any attempt to steal Ukraine
land through violence and Terror
colleagues while the war goes on while
Russia is hastily trying to change
Ukraine's map the human rights
commissioning of inquiry Human Rights
Council Commission of inquiry on Ukraine
has concluded based on evidence that war
crimes have been committed by the
Russian Federation in Ukraine last week
in this chamber ICC prosecutor General
said that the bodies lying on the
streets he saw in butcher were real not
staged
crimes Committee in Ukraine are being
meticulously documented they will not be
prescribed and will follow perpetrators
until their last days
also we in the security Council cannot
stay idle as we heard from the U.S
delegation together we have prepared the
job resolution to condemn the Sham
referendums which has been shared with
the council members
borders cannot change to satisfy
Russia's appetite and Ukraine is not and
it cannot be Russia we must stay United
and continue helping Ukraine defend
itself and get its territory back I
thank you
Lord
declaration is
president
I also want to thank usgd Carlo for your
briefing I'm president zielinski for
your statement
the president of Ukraine used the phrase
sham referenda Ireland fully agrees
we condemn the Sham referendum being
conducted in occupied Ukrainian
territory by Russia or its proxies
no one who believes in and is fully
committed to the principles enshrined in
the U.N Charter of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of States could do
otherwise
why is this
because this referenda the Sham
referenda are both illegal and
illegitimate
they are illegal because they violate
the U.N Charter and Russia's obligations
under international law including the
law of occupation
they also ignore Ukraine's Constitution
which provides a legal basis for any
referenda that would affect the
territorial boundaries of Ukraine
and they are illegitimate because they
do not reflect the popular or freely
expressed will of the Ukrainian people
as we've previously heard in this
chamber over 1 million people from those
occupied territories have been moved to
Russia
this is as a result of Russia's military
Invasion including by forced deportation
in fact more than 7 million people are
internally displaced within Ukraine
because of this war
Mr President these referenda will never
deter us from supporting the people of
Ukraine
might does not make right
nor will they have any legal or
political effect on the status of the
operation nuclear power plant or other
Ukrainian nuclear facilities
these referenda are a cynical ploy to
not only further undermine Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
but also to try and reset an unjustified
War
this is a blatant land grab to redefine
areas of Ukraine as part of Russia a
blatant land grab
Mr president Ukraine has had a hard one
Independence
it has had a hard-won path to
establishing itself as a sovereign
democracy free from foreign interference
it is sticking bravely to this choice no
matter what has been thrown at us
in particular Ireland condemns Russia's
nuclear threats and all nuclear threats
whether explicit or implicit regardless
of circumstance
Ireland once again calls on Russia to
end its aggression immediately to comply
with obligations under international law
and withdraw all forces unconditionally
from The Sovereign territory of Ukraine
the people of Ukraine as much as the
people elsewhere in the world who are
suffering the devastating impact of this
war deserve no less thank you Mr
President
is
thank you Mr President I will very
briefly intervene I thank under
Secretary General Rosemary DiCarlo for
her remarks
Mr President as stated by my minister in
this very council at the last meeting on
this subject the trajectory of the
Ukraine conflict is a matter of profound
concern for the International Community
India has repeatedly called for an
immediate cessation of hostilities and
the need to resolve the ongoing conflict
through dialogue and diplomacy
this was also stated unequivocally by
Prime Minister Modi during his meeting
with President Putin in the sidelines of
the recent SEO Summit in Tashkent
we firmly believe that the global order
should be anchored on international law
the U.N Charter and respect for the
sovereignty and the territorial
Integrity of states
India's approach to the Ukraine conflict
will continue to be human-centric
on our part we are providing both
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine and
economic support to some of our
neighbors in the global South under
economic distress even as they stare at
the escalating costs of food of fuel and
of fertilizers which has been a
consequential Fallout of the ongoing
conflict
Mr President the need of the hour is to
end the conflict in Ukraine and return
to the negotiating table
this has already resulted in the loss of
countless lives and miseries for people
particularly for women children and the
elderly with Millions becoming homeless
and forced to take shelter in
neighboring countries
let us all work together to ensure that
this comes to an early end thank you
declaration is
thank you Mr President I would like to
begin
my statement by thanking USG Rosemary
dicado for her briefing
We join other speakers
and expressing our deep concerns about
the ongoing warship and aggression
against Ukraine
in violation of the fundamental
principles of international law
especially relating to sovereignty
territory Integrity political
Independence
and the recognition of states
The Invasion against Ukraine under mines
in our view the purposes and principles
of our Charter
and stands in contrast to the Norms
which have guided recent Interstate
relations
and given endurance to the International
System
as confirmed by several heads of state
and government
during the just and the general debates
of the general assembly
the impact of the war has had palpable
effects on the lives of millions of
people across the world
it is their desire that this war
and many such others he ended as soon as
possible for peace to prevail
we therefore caution against heightened
and Rachel Rick and give an expression
to contemplations that threaten the use
of nuclear weapons
as that can only lead into the darker
base of a nuclear catastrophe with no
witness
we urge maximum restraints by all sides
and what has so far been an effort at
conventional Warfare
Mr President Ghana is particularly
concerned about the ongoing referendum
in the ridgings of the nurse luhansk
question and operation
we regret the attempts that are being
made to disintegrate the legitimate
authority of the government of Ukraine
over a state territory
the process of the referendum as we have
heard
can least be described as free Fair
Democratic or reflective of the role of
the people of Ukraine
we reiterate our brain support position
against acquisition of territory through
the threats
or use of force
we cannot continue to live in power
universes and accordingly urge the
International Community
to use the full weight of its will to
serve as a bulwark against such
practices
which have a prosperity to unravel the
tennis global stability that we
presently have
we notice of concerned unfortunate
Rising humanitarian casualties as
fighting continues in the Eastern
and Southern parts of Ukraine
unless an immediate ceasefire is reached
the escalation of military combat would
result in further dire consequences for
all
we therefore retrace our call for an
immediate sization of hostilities
we also call on the parties to refrain
from targeting civilians and destroying
civilian infrastructure
in accordance with the obligations under
International humanitarian law and human
rights law
we age the Russian Federation which has
often attempted to situated Special
Operations within the Ambit of
international law
to respect the sovereignty of Ukraine
and withdraw its truths on
internationally recognized borders of
its neighbor
Mr President to save that International
Peace and security
imagine gently deepen diplomacy and
widen International Air Force to Defuse
The Rising Global tensions
so as to facilitate a peaceful
settlement of the conflict
the situation in Ukraine reinforces the
imperative for a reformed and responsive
Council
that is able to address all threats to
International Peace and security
including by All actors
pending the much needed reforms we must
continue to work together in finding
pragmatic ways
to address the challenges that confront
our collective security I thank you Mr
President
foreign
thank you president
let me thank under Secretary General
DeCarlo for her briefing
and I welcome the participation of
president zielinski in this meeting
Mr President
Russia's holding of Sham referenda in
Donetsk luhansk zapparisha and Herson
regions of Ukraine is an egregious
violation of Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
and of the principles of the UN Charter
as the UN have told us today
this process is both illegal and
illegitimate
it is a Shameless propaganda effort
aimed at justifying Russia's illegal
presence on Sovereign Ukrainian
territory
we have seen Russia's referendum
Playbook before in Crimea
we see it playing out again now
disinformation intimidation
and Fabrication
has my foreign secretary told the
council last week
we know that President Putin is planning
to rig the outcome
these are regions that voted
overwhelmingly to join an independent
Ukraine in 1991.
and to back president zielinski in 2019
when given a free vote
their choice has been clear
to be part of a free independent
Democratic Ukraine
since invading Russia's control in these
regions has been through violence
torture
filtration and forced deportation
we've all seen images of soldiers with
automatic rifles accompanying the
ballots as they move from door to door
forcing ukrainians to take part
any referenda held on the under these
conditions at the barrel of a gun can
never be remotely close to free or Fair
and the Very idea that a referendum on
the fundamental question could be held
at three days notice in the middle of a
war zone is frankly farcical
we must all unequivocally reject these
illegitimate actions and Russian
attempts to illegally Annex Ukrainian
territory
and support the draft resolution the U.S
and Albania have brought forward today
colleagues this is a critical moment
there is no middle ground
no member of the United Nations should
turn a blind eye to Russia tearing up
the principles of the UN Charter
if we allow Russia to believe it can
change Sovereign borders by force
then the entire system on which we base
our shared Safety and Security is under
threatened
these potemkin referenda
as well as Putin's decision to mobilize
Russian men to fight in his illegal War
our admissions that his invasion is
failing
instead of sending thousands more of his
own citizens to their death
and inflicting further destruction on
Ukraine
he should end this census War today
thank you
declaration is
thank you Mr President
I think under secretary DiCarlo for her
briefing
Brazil shares the concerns about the
referenda in regions of Ukraine
in the current conditions this is yet
another step that leads to an escalation
of the conflict
far from expressing the the will of the
people of donensk
lugenskerson and japorigi regions the
referenda tends to make the prospect of
Peace negotiations even more distant
the U.N Charter and the international
confidence on civil and political rights
and on economical social and culture and
cultural rights recognize the
inalienable right of All Peoples to
self-determination and to freely decide
their political status
this is a fundamental principle of
international law which is the very
basis of the legitimacy of states
many times before especially in the
context of decolonization the holding of
referenda was the means chosen for
peoples to express their free will
resolutions of this Council established
the use of this instrument as a
legitimate practice today to decide on
issues of sovereignty and territorial
integrity
its validity however depends on certain
conditions
it is an unreasonable to assume that
populations in areas in Conflict are
able to freely Express their will
International practice recommends that
referenda on questions of sovereignty be
conducted in a transparent manner
without restrictions on freedom of
expression and with the possibility of
monitoring by independent Observers
this does not seem to be the case for
the aforementioned regions of Ukraine
Brazil stands by the principles of
respecting territorial integrity
or political Unity of sovereign and
Independence
and independently States
Mr President we reiterate our call
foreign for an immediate ceasefire
and the opening of Peace negotiations
the Istanbul agreements in July and last
week's prisoner exchanges were positive
signs that demonstrates the value of
diplomacy in reducing the human
suffering resulting from this conflict
these are defenses while extremely
relevant are insufficient
it is essential that the part is
refrained from adopting measures that
resulting in an escalation of
hostilities including historical terms
the moment calls for restraint and
pragmatism
we believe that this council is
primarily a forum for negotiation and
for dialogue so far we have collectively
failed to find the Creative Solutions to
the conflict
negotiation and dialogue advocated by
most members in their interventions over
the past seven months less opposes our
willingness to listen
perhaps we should ask ourselves how
sensitive we are to the concerns of
others
especially to the lives of those on the
ground which should come before any
political considerations and I thank you
Mexico
gracias president
reference
foreign
in consequence yeah exortimes
de la fuerta International
s
resolutions
China
chemistry
foreign
[Music]
taken serious
Ness
[Music]
Mr President
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to include response
bring
National
subscribe
foreign
the Christ
oh thank you Mr President and welcome
back
I thank USG Rosemary DiCarlo for her
briefing on the dire situation in
Ukraine we again send our heartfelt
condolences to all ukrainians who are
suffering the physical psychological and
economic ravages of War
we are very concerned with the reports
of referenda being held in donets luhans
Carson
and their impact on Ukraine status as a
member of the United Nations and on
International Peace and security
the U.N Secretary General has stated
clearly and I quote him any annexation
of a state's territory by another state
resulting from the threat or use of
force is a violation of the U.N Charter
and of international law
close quote
this is the fundamental truth that
should be heeded by the Russian
Federation and all members of the United
Nations
the referenda
will undermine the prospects of a longer
term negotiated peace settlement
by attempting to create a fatal complete
they will encourage those who are
increasingly put their faith in the
strengthening of armed alliances in
preparation for war
as if this were not sufficiently
alarming we have heard serious threats
being made of the use of weapons of mass
destruction
to pull back from the brink of disaster
Kenya calls for an immediate cessation
of hostilities and a stop to all
attempts to unilaterally alter
internationally recognized borders
Mr President
are frequent briefings debates and
consultations on the situation in
Ukraine are taking place as the economic
and conflict situations in different
parts of the world get worse
unfortunately the most powerful actors
are focusing far more on this conflict
in Europe than on any other crisis there
appears to be little appetite and
because of this war even less Unity to
deliver the reforms and policies that we
all know are needed
Mr President bold action is required to
hold the extreme food
insecurity and even starvation in the
world
the world fruit program has calculated
that in that in Eastern Africa just as
an example fertilizer prices have more
than doubled in the last year and
especially so since the invasion of
Ukraine
fuel prices have also risen sharply
wfp calculates that the result will be a
year-on-year decline of 16 percent in
cereal production representing 7.2
million metric tons
in an already food insecure region the
impact will be to increase the number of
hungry people by almost 7 million this
situation is reflected in other regions
it is a matter of life and death for All
actors to respond to the global food
insecurity crisis the Black Sea grain
initiative and the agreement to ensure
unimpeded exports of Russian food and
fertilizer to world markets were a
promising start it is imperative that
all institutions that are enforcing
compliance with sanctions ensure that
all unintended blockages are removed
there are sufficient reports of negative
secondary effects on banking Insurance
transport and other critical enabling
mechanisms
we also urge major grain and fertilizer
producers to avoid stockpiling and
breaking delivery contracts ongoing
plans to create emergency mechanisms in
this regard may be at the serious
detriment of Global Food security
we urge that any efforts to design and
deploy emergency food and energy
security mechanisms be accompanied by
planning for transformed Food Systems in
the most food insecure regions
a major part of this would be making the
necessary investment in sharply
increasing agricultural productivity
particularly in Africa
doing so is key to preventing cycles of
humanitarian crisis and the declining
donor-funded responses to the worst of
them
it will also allow investing in climate
change resilient Food Systems at a time
when catastrophic effects are being
experienced in multiple regions
finally greater production increased
storage and sufficient transport
infrastructure will lead to low food
prices and therefore greater political
stability
Mr President the multilateral system
cannot continue as it is today
the major powers are so bent on
protecting and projecting their
interests and security concerns that
they seem unable to act in the broader
interests of our United Nations
today the inaugurable truth is that the
protections afforded by membership of
this organization are insufficient
rather than the charter granting us
equality we are governed by the
destructive logic encapsulated by the
saying and I quote the question of
Justice only enters where there is equal
power to enforce it and that the
powerful exact what they can and the
weak suffer what they must
it is time we sought real changes in
global institutions including this
Security Council it is time for real
inclusion and real fairness
we can start with procedural rules in
the council and eventually make changes
to the Charter
the reform should not be limited to
allowing other only other major Powers a
seat at the table
it is clear from the historical record
that the voice and presence of
developing countries with no major
military interest to protect regionally
or globally needs to be strengthened
significantly
a multilateralism founded on the
principle of the powerful exacting what
they can while the weak suffer what they
must is a poor protection against the
scourge of War as we are all witnessed
today
Madam president
or Mr President sorry
Kenya reaffirms once more its
recognition of Ukraine sovereignty and
territorial Integrity within its
internationally recognized borders thank
you
ability
Mr President
I would like to begin by thanking under
Secretary General Rosemary DeCarlo for
her updates
having just concluded this year's
high-level week of the general assembly
a resounding message we heard from many
world leaders remains at the Forefront
of our minds
the world wants peace in Ukraine
it seems however that we are moving
further away from this common objective
of peace and stability
the referendums that are now underway
further complicate efforts for a
peaceful resolution to this conflict
in order to be credible and sustainable
any processes that aim to bring us
closer to peace must be inclusive and
any actions that undermine this
prospects for constructive dialogue must
be avoided by all parties
we re-emphasize the need to respect the
principles of territorial Integrity
sovereignty and Independence which are
core to the UN Charter and Central to
constructive relations between states
these principles protect all states
equally whether large or small and
collectively we must not allow their
erosion
in Pursuit Of Peace this Council has an
essential role in preserving these
principles prioritizing the peaceful
settlement of disputes and maintaining
International Peace and security
we recall here the January 2022 joint
statement of the permanent members of
this Council affirming that a nuclear
war cannot be won and must never be
fought
over the past few months we have seen
incremental movement between the parties
that has led to tangible positive
outcomes on concrete issues
we commend the United Nations and others
that have facilitated constructive
engagement in this regard
most recently the fruits of these
efforts have included prisoner exchanges
conducted with the assistance of turkey
and Saudi Arabia and agreements related
to the export of grains and fertilizer
which have helped to alleviate pressure
on Global Food Supplies and prices
there is further potential to build on
these agreements moreover the direct
engagement that brought them to fruition
can help diffuse tensions and open a
pathway for conflict resolution
to this end the parties must be
supported in moving toward dialogue and
away from further escalation
we once again underline the necessity of
all parties abiding by their obligations
under international law and
international humanitarian law
Mr President the war has carried on for
over seven months with no sign of
abating
during this time nearly 14 and a half
million people were forced to flee their
homes with more than 7 million of them
now displaced across Europe
humanitarian costs have been immense
with more than 17 million people in need
of humanitarian assistance
it is long past time for this conflict
to come to an end
for that to happen we continue to
emphasize the importance of an immediate
cessation of hostilities throughout
Ukraine
additionally it is essential to build on
and amplify positive developments
between the parties so we can begin to
pull back from this dangerous point of
heightened Global tensions
what we need now is to secure a piece
that is sustainable and in accordance
with the UN Charter and international
law
thank you Mr President
is
thank you president
thank usgd Carlo for her briefing
in the last day
we have all seen images of armed Russian
soldiers going door to door in occupied
parts of Ukraine to collect votes for a
so-called for a so-called referendum on
joining Russia
this is a phony pretext from the
aggressor Russia to try to Annex more
parts of Ukraine
and let me be clear Ukraine has not
authorized this referenda and Norway
rejects these Russian Fabrication in
occupied regions of Ukraine
whatever outcome Russia announces they
remain contrary to international law
have no legal effects and would in no
way change Ukraine's sovereignty within
its International recognized borders
President we are also clear that no
territorial acquisition resulting from
use of force shall be recognized as
lawful
and that no Russian claims to a next
territory can take away Ukraine's right
to defend its own land
all States including Russia have an
obligation under Article 2 of the
charter of the United Nations to refrain
in their international relations from
the threat or use of force against the
territorial integrity and political
independence of any state
and to settle their international
disputes by peaceful means
Russia's announcement of the
mobilization of reserved forces is
another issue a grave concern it is a
dangerous escalation which will lead to
increased suffering for people in all
parts of Ukraine
president unspeakable Horrors very
relieved in Butcher initsum and other
places occupied by Russian forces
the independent International Commission
of inquiry on Ukraine concluding
concluded in the update given last
Friday that war crimes have been
committed in Ukraine by Russia
the use of explosive weapons in
populated areas have been a source of
immense harm and suffering not
distinguishing between civilians and
combatants
adults or children
the commission also found a council ill
treatment and torture carried out during
unlawful confinement
and that Russian soldiers have committed
sexual and gender-based violence
the age of victims range from 4 to 82
years
the commission has documented cases in
which children have been raped tortured
and unlawfully confined
Norway condemns these acts in the
strongest terms and call for
accountability for the perpetrators
president this war has had abhorrent
impacts on the people of Ukraine and now
is being felt across the globe
we must work urgently to bring it to an
end
Norway expresses its full support for
the Secretary General skilled offices
and when the time comes we will stand
firmly with the un's effort to build and
sustain peace
the Ukrainian people are paying with
their lives to defend Universal values
and their own independence
Ukraine can count on Norway's continued
support
Russia must stop the war and fully
immediately and unconditionally withdraw
its forces and military equipment from
all territory of Ukraine
and again Norwell would never recognize
these so-called referenda and we stand
by Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
thank you
declaration
is
a situations
Pacific
foreign
foreign
Federation
is
a stories
foreign
Ukraine
Annapolis University
Society
foreign
industry
is
infrastructure
[Music]
history questions
foreign
University
interview
s
is that strongly
foreign
Democratic School
but there's no need to call him units
foreign
thank you
again
foreign
however
you guys
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
territory
foreign
issue
he was really it was religious images
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right
propaganda
is
Christmas movies
Europe
an Union
foreign
history
truth really is thank you
thank you merci representative the
refrigeration
foreign
[Music]
foreign
operation
foreign
referendum
is
stationary
the temperatures
in foreign
reality
is
the situations
um thank you Mr President and I hate
asking for the floor one second time
since it gives me the impression I was
not clear enough but in this case I need
to this is not to prolong the discussion
of course everything is clear but to put
the record straight
the Russian delegation made again a
parallel with the Republic of Kosovo
independent country that has been
recognized by half of the United Nations
including half of this Council this is
wrong inaccurate and regrettable I have
already reacted to similar remarks on
this last June therefore I'll be very
short nothing could be more artificial
and first than comparing an
international effort to end the conflict
protect civilians and establish a peace
process to finally lost in solution
which was the case of Kosovo with a pure
and unprovoked aggression and the Sham
referendums engineered in Moscow that
are being carried out now in Ukraine no
one is can or will be fooled by this no
attempts to compare the incomparable no
easy shortcuts out of any historic and
political context will help Russia
divert attention from its war of choice
in Ukraine or hide its blatant breach of
international law which has made it an
international para kosovan Serbia are
bound to lay by our dialogue to solve
their problems they meet they do not
fight
and above all the insurer is not Kosovo
any part of the world it's Russia's
aggression Russia's crimes Russia's
territory grab to the detriment of its
neighbor we will not be misled I think
the representation is
um
taking place in the territory that we're
talking about are they calling for a
completely different approach here thank
you
Lord